the rare Awards program was created to
recognize and reward deserving students
with technology school supplies and more
here to tell us more is Mike Del Prado
he's the president of executive option
welcome to the show hey thank you very
much for having me so the the rare
Awards program what is it uh the
remarkable achievements recognized
everyday award program is uh was created
to recognize deserving students with
uh with prizes uh ranging from school
supplies to technology technology being
like maybe laptops iPads laptops iPads
in parallel we're also offering a um a
you know a lucky student with a ten
thousand dollar scholarship yeah I want
to touch on that but first what made you
and your company decide to start this
this is something very special that
you're doing for for Las Vegas students
you know given a two-year pandemic you
know many families with school-aged
children have run into you know have
been impacted one way or another
this is an opportunity for us to and you
know motivate the you know the students
and families to continue the fight move
forward and progress over time you know
with the with their educational track in
their dreams you can't give up you can't
give up on the streets are here to
support them okay this scholarship it's
a ten thousand dollar scholarship yeah
absolutely wow that's huge okay who is
who can register for the scholarship how
do we go about trying to get this
scholarship absolutely so uh right now
it's uh you know it's a selected school
so we do uh it's High School seniors
between for uh Cheyenne and Desert Pine
High School okay also undergrads and CSN
and UNLV can apply for that okay the
difference between that and the other
one is the other one is nomination based
so uh the School faculty or peer
students can nominate students between
from K to 12 for those prizes as it
relates to the scholarship they can
apply for themselves and where do they
apply because I know we mentioned a ten
thousand dollars right now they're doing
their stuff and they're ten thousand
dollar scholarships like what how do I
apply how do they get involved in how do
we apply right so if they log in if they
go to uh execops.us forward slash rare
r-a-r-e
um it'll give them instructions and
Direction on how to apply okay and uh
that both on both aspects as well so and
what else do you guys have coming up for
2023 because this is huge but I know you
guys are doing a lot with students what
else do you guys have coming up this is
our uh our first stop you know first
opportunities we're trying this out what
we want to do is expand to more schools
through the whole district and as a
matter of fact to the whole state
eventually right so that's our goal
right now we're testing the waters with
these schools and see if it works out if
it's and I'm assuming it's going to it's
going to work on it yeah and we're going
to make it happen I love it Mike thank
you so much for joining the show one
more time the website for for everyone
uh executive Ops
uh dot us forward slash rare oh
beautiful it's on the screen right now
thank you lots of information on the
rare scholarship program visit as you
said
executiveops.us slash rare now
applications are open until January 31st